welcome back thanks to SMG Media Group
Rocky is introducing us to microverse
Studios a company inspiring the present
and the future through scientific
animation
Cameron welcome to Las Vegas now thank
you Rocky so I cannot wait to introduce
everybody to your super cool company and
career but first we got to start with
what's behind you those look like
trophies what are you winning over there
yeah yeah these are actual film Awards a
couple years ago we decided to check and
see whether our scientific animations uh
could actually win base like film Awards
based on their aesthetic and it turns
out they did pretty well they can yours
can
um introduce us to your to your company
you're the CEO
reverse studio so what do you guys do
yeah so uh we we serve the biotech and
pharmaceutical Industries and some to a
certain extent the academic Industries
uh with
um 3D animations that explain how their
Technologies and discoveries operate on
a cellular and molecular level okay
Cameron that went way over my head and
probably over some people's eyes out
there so explain how you can or how the
general public can use this
yeah so uh what a lot of times ends up
happening is when well there's two two
different General ways that our
animations get used number one is it
gets uh used to communicate to doctors
how a drug works so that that doctor can
make a more educated decision
um you know there's so many drugs out
there for all kinds of different
ailments and the doctors a lot of times
have to deal with a lot of information
um so the animation makes it easy and
palatable and acceptable accessible for
them which impacts the patient because
the doctors are able to to absorb a lot
more information that way the second way
is for investors so a lot of times
biotech startups and so forth need to
explain how their revolutionary
Technologies work in a very quick uh
period of time and so the in order to
communicate to investors the those
biotechs will work with us to try to
make sure that their messages quickly
understandable
oh wow this is so interesting so for
anyone interested in a career like this
I guess you would tell them that it's
not just scientific it's also like fine
art oh yeah yeah it's both it's really
heavily both in fact um you know for me
my whole degree was science and art in
parallel uh for undergrad and then
graduate degree was actually a medical
illustration master's program and for
anybody hoping to get into this kind of
um a career I strongly encourage them to
look at you know those master's degrees
programs just like foreign United States
I'm actually a professor at one of them
um and these um these programs will give
you everything that you need to become a
scientific communicator and it's a
fantastic and growing uh uh industry wow
what what school can you can you tell us
just in case someone wants to follow you
sure sure University of Illinois at
Chicago
um that's that's where I'm a faculty um
but we also a lot of my team actually
volunteers at the medical uh sorry the
Augusta University's medical
illustration graduate program as well I
would say Vegas is a science and art
Town believe it or not and you guys have
a
indeed yeah the association of medical
illustrators it's a big meeting for our
industry is going to be descending on
Las Vegas uh at the end of July
um and we'll have I mean we're not that
many maybe somewhere between
400 and 800 people show up um and it's a
lot of a lot of art a lot of fun a lot
of academics
thank you to SMG Media Group for
sponsoring this segment for more
information on microverse Studios head
to microversestudios.com we'll be right
back
[Music]